.
Um 18.15 Uhr fängt es an.
Ich werde früher losfahren -
man weiss nie, ob unten Stau ist.
Irgendwo
sind noch die Wohnungsschlüssel.
Nein, hier sind sie nicht.
Ich bin etwas durcheinander. Ich
finde meine Wohnungsschlüssel nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
die Aufregung.
Ah ja, hier sind sie, in der Küche.
* Gläserne, schwebende Klänge *
Lieber ein bisschen früher losfahren
als zu spät.
Es macht keinen guten Eindruck,
wenn man zu spät zur Anhörung kommt.
Das Schweizer Einbürgerungsverfahren
ist das strengste in ganz Europa.
Zwar gibt es
nur einen Schweizer Pass,
aber über 2'000 Wege,
ihn zu bekommen.
Das entspricht der Anzahl Gemeinden
in unserem Land.
Zum ersten Mal haben kommunale
Behörden aller vier Sprachregionen
Zutritt zu ihren sehr
vertraulichen Anhörungen gewährt.
Beim entscheidenden Schritt
vor der Kommission
müssen die Bewerbenden ihre Swissness
unter Beweis stellen und zeigen,
dass sie das Räderwerk,
das unser Land antreibt,
bis ins kleinste Detail kennen.
Willkommen
in der Einbürgerungsfabrik,
willkommen bei "Fabrique des Suisse",
"Far Svizzers",
"La Fabrica Dei Svizzeri",
"Schweizer machen".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Solenthaler: Bildung,
Lienert: Gesellschaft.
Herrmann, Schnellmann.
Landolt, Schnellmann,
Lienert und Homberger.
Bereits vor sieben Monaten
paukte Andreas intensiv.
Damals ging es um den kantonalen
Test, den er mit Bravour bestand.
Heute gilt es,
die nächste Hürde zu nehmen.
Der gebürtige Ostdeutsche
muss vor der Einbürgerungsbehörde
seiner Gemeinde antraben.
Ist alles okay?
Ich habe noch eine Frage
zu diesem Privatkreditvertrag hier.
Diese Frage
stellten wir ihm ebenfalls.
Er schrieb zurück, dass er damit
seine Pensionskasse verbessert habe.
Er hat explizit Einkäufe
in die 2. Säule gemacht.
Und er hat ... Darf ich kurz?
Direkt vor dem Gespräch prüft Annina
Herrmann, Mitglied der Behörde,
Andreas' Dossier
noch einmal kritisch.
Bei Fragen kann sie sich auf
die Gemeindeschreiberin verlassen.
Wenn er den Betrag für seinen
Lebensunterhalt gebraucht hätte,
wäre es nicht gut gewesen.
Dann wären seine Finanzen
nicht geordnet gewesen,
aber für Einkäufe
finde ich es in Ordnung.
Gut, bis später.
- Tschüss.
Ich würde es so ausdrücken,
dass sie sich bis
auf die Unterhose ausziehen müssen.
Es ... Ja.
Wenn man von der Gemeinde die
Aufforderung bekommt, hinzugehen,
ist die Vorbereitung dafür hart.
Man weiss nicht,
was einem da widerfährt.
Am besten nimmt man ein Lexikon über
die Schweiz und lernt es auswendig.
* Einzelne, dumpfe Klänge *
Vielleicht noch schnell
zu den Vorbereitungspapieren:
Vor über fünf Jahren
beging er eine Übertretung,
erhielt eine Busse von 200 Fr.
Das Amt für Migration
hat bei "negative Akten"
Ja angekreuzt.
Deshalb habe ich das aufgeführt.
Aber es ist nicht relevant,
es ist nur eine Übertretung.
Die grosse Stunde ist gekommen.
Andreas steht unter enormem Druck.
Zum Stress,
den die eigene Anhörung auslöst,
kommt die Erinnerung
an das Scheitern seiner Tochter Lisa.
Guten Abend.
- (Frau) Guten Abend.
Vor fünf Jahren ist seine Tochter
in ebendiesem Saal
vor ebendieser Behörde abgeblitzt.
Nach dem negativen Entscheid
verliess Lisa die Schweiz definitiv.
Andreas blieb allein zurück.
So, Herr Luther -
ein sehr prominenter Name,
ich nehme an,
500-jährig oder noch älter.
Nun stehen Sie
vor der Einbürgerungsbehörde -
Sie möchte ja Schweizer werden.
Es läuft folgendermassen:
Ich werde die Fragen stellen.
Annina Herrmann
gehörte der Behörde an,
die Lisa prüfte
und durchfallen liess.
Sie will nicht auf die Anhörung
von damals zurückkommen.
Sie haben die C-Bewilligung?
- Mhm.
Mit der C-Bewilligung
können Sie in der Schweiz bleiben.
Sie haben alles, was wir auch haben,
ausser dass Sie nicht abstimmen
und wählen können.
Was hat Sie bewogen,
Schweizer werden zu wollen?
Man lebt hier und möchte auch
am Entscheidungsprozess teilnehmen.
Ohne Stimmrecht
hat man dieses Recht nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich hier in der Gemeinde
zu Hause, integriert?
Ja.
Ja?
Wie äussert sich das?
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Umfeld?
Mit meinem Vermieter
habe ich sehr, sehr guten Kontakt.
Wir gehen wandern,
wir grillen zusammen
und waren schon gemeinsam im Urlaub.
Gut, nun kommen wir
zu einem anderen Thema:
Können Sie uns zwei Bäche
in der Gemeinde Freienbach nennen?
Zwei was?
- Bäche.
Annina Herrmann stellt die Fragen
auf Schweizerdeutsch.
Für sie ist es unvorstellbar, dass
ein Kandidat integriert sein soll,
der die Landessprache nicht kann.
Staldenbach.
- Staldenbach, genau.
Dann haben wir noch?
(Mann)
Bitte, machen Sie es sich bequem.
Wir sind nicht da,
um einen Test abzuhalten
oder um Fangfragen zu stellen.
Wir machen hier nicht
auf gemeine Prüfer.
Wir sind hier,
um Sie kennenzulernen,
weil wir den Gemeinderat vertreten.
13 Jahre, nachdem er aus Eritrea
in die Schweiz geflüchtet ist,
sitzt Dawit mit Tochter Hermela
vor der Einbürgerungskommission.
Ob die beiden die Schweizer
Staatsangehörigkeit bekommen,
wird sich in den nächsten 30 Min.
entscheiden.
In diesem kurzen Treffen
werden wir uns mit Ihren Kenntnissen
über unser Land befassen.
Gut, zuerst vielen Dank Ihnen allen.
Ich heisse Dawit Mengstab
und komme aus Eritrea.
Ich wohne seit fast zwölf Jahren
im Tessin.
Hier habe ich alles gemacht,
hier habe ich mein Leben geändert,
habe eine Lehre als Plattenleger
gemacht.
Aber als ich dann als Plattenleger
arbeitete,
hatte ich Probleme
wegen Klebstoffallergien.
Ich musste den Beruf aufgeben
und einen anderen Weg einschlagen.
Ich liess mich im MediaMarkt
in Grancia zum Verkäufer umschulen.
Was machen Sie heute?- Ich
arbeite noch immer im MediaMarkt.
Perfekt - fahren Sie fort.
Meine Frau macht eine Ausbildung zur
Geschäftsführerin im Gastgewerbe,
ausserdem arbeitet sie als Dol-
metscherin im ganzen Kanton Tessin.
Das Finanzielle macht Dawit Sorgen.
Sein befristeter Umschulungsvertrag
läuft bald aus
und sein Arbeitgeber
hat ihm noch nichts versprochen.
Sein Lohn reicht nur knapp
für die ganze Familie.
Ein Kriterium, das das Gesetz
für die Integration vorgibt,
ist die wirtschaftliche Integration.
Das heisst, dass die Person
für sich aufkommen können muss.
Hier im Tessin habe ich geheiratet,
meine beiden Kinder
sind hier geboren.
Sie spielen beim FC Rapid.
Alle beide.
Gehen Sie mit zu den Spielen?
An den Wochenenden begleite ich sie.
Wenn ich arbeite,
geht meine Frau mit.
Nehmen Sie während Ihrer Freizeit
am Leben in Lugano teil?
Am Stadtleben?
Ja, wenn Musikfeste sind,
z.B. der Jazz Corner,
oder während des Karnevals
bin ich in der Stadt unterwegs.
Auch mit den Kindern.
Einige Kandidaten wissen
nicht mal den Namen des Parks,
in dem wir uns befinden,
den Ciani-Park.
Oder sie kennen
den Namen des Flusses nicht,
der durch die Stadt fliesst,
der Cassarate.
Während die Anhörung von Dawit
in Lugano weitergeht,
hat im kleinen Engadiner Kurort
der Alltagsstress
Familie Corona-Cardoso
wieder fest im Griff.
Den entscheidenden Schritt, die Anhö-
rung vor der Einbürgerungskommission,
haben sie hinter sich,
doch der Entscheid steht noch aus.
* Sie sprechen italienisch. *
Ich lebe nun seit 26 Jahren
im Engadin.
Ich habe alle Restaurants
der Gegend getestet
und mich dabei für eigene Rezepte
inspirieren lassen.
Capuns.
Paolo hofft,
dass er mit all seinem Wissen
vor der Einbürgerungskommission
punkten konnte.
Ungeduldig
wartet er auf den Entscheid,
ob seine Familie
die Staatsbürgerschaft bekommt.
Es ist ein kräftezehrender Weg,
aber es lohnt sich.
Mangia sta mousse.
Es sind ein paar schwierige Fragen,
aber ich finde es schon wichtig,
dass, wenn du den Pass eines
anderen Landes bekommen willst,
du auch integriert bist
und Interesse hast,
dass du den nicht einfach bekommst.
Ich hatte mich auf den Test gefreut.
Wenn ich ihn bestehe,
kann ich sagen,
dass ich es verdient habe,
weil ich viel geübt
und gelernt habe.
Guten Morgen, Irene.
- Morgen.
Im Moment steckt Chiara in einer
anderen wichtigen Phase ihres Lebens.
Sie muss sich entscheiden,
wie es beruflich weitergehen soll.
Ihre Praktikumsstelle
hat sie nicht zufällig gewählt.
Papi?
Die 15-Jährige
spricht vier Sprachen fliessend -
eine ideale Voraussetzung in einer
Region, die ganz vom Tourismus lebt.
Va bene.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
was ich nach der Schule machen soll.
Welche Lehrstelle.
Ob im Gastgewerbe
oder doch lieber im Tourismus.
Das hat miteinander zu tun.
Und ich kann
all meine Sprachkenntnisse brauchen.
Es ist viel schöner, mit Namen
als mit Zahlen zu arbeiten.
Man ist ja keine Nummer
im Sinne von "Ich bin Zimmer 112".
"Nein, Sie sind Herr Meier",
sage ich dann.
So, kommen Sie mit.
Einige Hundert Meter vom Engadinerhof
entfernt, im Gemeindezentrum,
entscheiden Thomas Walther
und seine Einbürgerungskommission
über das Schicksal
der Familie Corona-Cardoso.
Gut. Gibt es noch Fragen,
Bemerkungen zu ihnen?
Heute geht es um die Einbürgerung
der Familie Corona.
Sie ist euch bekannt, ihr konntet
das Dossier vorgängig einsehen.
Hier werden die Anhörungen von
kleineren Delegationen durchgeführt,
um den Eindruck einer
Gerichtsverhandlung zu vermeiden.
Der Schlussentscheid
wird dann im Plenum gefällt.
Eure Eindrücke?
Es ist effektiv so,
wie man sie im Dorf wahrnimmt.
Sie waren sehr gut
auf das Gespräch vorbereitet.
Sie konnten zwar nicht
alle Fragen beantworten,
aber sie haben sich am Schluss
noch selbst Fragen gestellt,
haben dort ergänzt
und wieder gepunktet.
Das ist eine Familie, die wir
mit gutem Gewissen aufnehmen können.
Das Mädchen ist fröhlich
und ...
... man sieht,
dass es eine intakte Familie ist.
Sie haben es schön zusammen und
sie sind mit Pontresina verbunden.
Ich denke,
sie haben es verdient,
dass wir Ja sagen.
Ja, es gibt unsererseits
überhaupt keine Einwände.
Im Gegenteil, sie sind sehr tüchtig,
ihr wisst das ja.
Für uns war klar,
dass wir sie einbürgern.
Es spricht nichts dagegen -
wenn nicht sie, wen dann?
Sie sprechen die Sprache,
sind bestens integriert,
erfüllen alle Voraussetzungen.
So ist das Gespräch
eine Pro-forma-Angelegenheit.
Sind wir dafür?
Gut. Gegenstimmen
müssen wir nicht zählen.
Dann unterschreiben wir die Urkunde
und erledigen den Schriftverkehr.
Dieses Bürgerrecht auf Gemeindeebene
ist nur ein erster Schritt.
Einbürgerungswillige müssen noch
das Kantonsbürgerrecht erlangen,
bevor sie die Schweizer
Staatsbürgerschaft erhalten.
Alle drei Elemente
braucht es zwingend,
um vollwertiger Schweizer,
vollwertige Schweizerin zu werden.
Im altehrwürdigen Palazzo Civico
in Lugano
wird jetzt Hermela
in die Zange genommen.
Nach dem neuen Gesetz dürfen Personen
ab zwölf Jahren angehört werden.
Können wir? Dann los
mit unserem kurzen Gespräch.
In welche Schule gehst du?
In die Sekundarschule in Viganello.
Dieses Jahr habe ich
die 8. Klasse abgeschlossen.
Und? Zeugnisse schon bekommen?
- Ja.
Und? Überall die Note 6?
Nein, keine Sechser.
Aber im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr
mit vielen Vieren
habe ich jetzt keine einzige,
nur 4,5 und 5.
Ich habe eben mehr gelernt.
Meine Mutter sagte, wir sollen
uns nicht stressen lassen,
uns aber auch nicht blamieren.
Sie sagte: "Sei ganz du.
Sag nur Dinge, die du auch denkst."
Dann bin ich rein, habe gesagt,
was ich denke,
und ehrlich
auf die Fragen geantwortet.
Dein Traumberuf?- Mein Traum
wäre es, Sängerin zu werden.
Aber dieses Jahr habe ich mich
v.a. mit Architektur befasst.
Ich möchte später mal
Architektin werden.
Weisst du, ob wir hier im Tessin
grosse Namen der Architektur haben?
Sie haben uns
einen Prospekt gegeben,
in dem einige Schulen
aufgelistet sind.
Eine der bekanntesten
Architekturschmieden?
Ich glaube,
es gibt eine in Mendrisio.
Bravissima,
Accademia di architettura.
Ich habe nichts vorbereitet.
Ich bin einfach hin und habe
ihre Fragen beantwortet, das war's.
Ich habe keine obligatorische
Schule im Tessin besucht,
Hermela schon.
Sie kennt sich in Geografie,
Geschichte und Wirtschaft aus.
Für sie ist es einfach,
sie kann auf jede Frage antworten.
Für mich ist das schwieriger -
deshalb musste ich so viel lernen.
Die Luganer Kommission hat mehr
Mitglieder als die meisten anderen.
Präsidiert von einem Lega-Mitglied
ist sie klar rechts positioniert,
spiegelt das politische
Kräfteverhältnis der Stadt.
Den 13 Personen im Saal gegenüber
zu sitzen, verlangt Dawit alles ab.
(Frau) Drei Seen im Kanton Schwyz?
Sihlsee, Wägitalersee, Lauerzersee.
Gut, zwei typische
Schweizer Musikinstrumente?
Andreas hat keine Ahnung,
was da auf ihn zukommt.
Freienbach hat einen Katalog mit
120 Musterfragen zusammengestellt,
aus denen Annina Herrmann
80 ausgewählt hat.
Zählt ja nicht dazu,
Kuhglocke, würde ich sagen.
Sie haben sicher schon
eine Ländlerkapelle gesehen?
Da gibt es alles Mögliche.
Also, z.B?
Sie haben Blasinstrumente ...
Schwyzerörgeli, z.B.
Was?
Schwyzerörgeli,
eine kleine Harmonika.
Quetschkommode.
- (Mehrere) Ja, genau.
Die wichtigsten Fragen sind sicher
diejenigen über die Gemeinde.
Der Bewerber muss wissen,
wo er wohnt,
was die Sitten und Bräuche sind,
er muss geografische Lokalkenntnisse
haben.
Dann hätten wir gerne drei Arbeit-
geber in der Gemeinde Freienbach.
EW Höfe.
Dann gibt es noch ...
Gegenüber von uns
ist z.B. auch noch ...
... Pflanz...
Gartenarchitektur.
Ja, und wie heisst der?
* Andreas seufzt. *
Martin Garten...
Sie dürfen auch grössere nennen.
Wir haben auch grosse Firmen hier.
Hm.
Grössere Firmen.
Baufirmen oder ...
Oh ja.
... oder wo Sie einkaufen gehen.
Ach so, ja.
Denner.
Die Hyundai-Autowerkstatt,
die Tankstelle.
Gut.
Friseursalon.
- Ja, ja. Gut.
Und die Post.
- Gut. Ja.
Gut, die nächste Frage:
Können Sie uns die Namen
von drei Gemeinderäten nennen?
Der Herr Landolt,
Lienert,
Stauffacher.
- Genau.
Wie viele Gemeinderäte haben wir?
- Sieben.
Sieben, genau. Wer wählt sie?
Die stimmberechtigte Bevölkerung.
- Ja.
Kennen Sie ...
... Museen im Kanton Schwyz?
Man weiss nicht,
was auf einen zukommt,
und kann bloss hoffen,
dass man nicht versagt.
Die Prüfungsangst macht sich breit
und es ist ... furchtbar,
eigentlich.
Museen?
Im ...
- (Mehrere) ... ganzen Kanton.
Im ganzen Kanton?
Oh ja. Hm.
In Schwyz
gibt es ein sehr wichtiges.
Dort befindet sich
ein sehr wichtiges Dokument ...
... für die Schweiz.
Das Bundesbriefmuseum.
Waren Sie schon dort?
Nein.
Schauen Sie es sich mal an.
Es ist sehr interessant.
Den sechs Kommissionsmitgliedern
gegenüber
fühlt sich Andreas immer unwohler.
Und in Lugano werden die Fragen
thematisch breiter.
Interessieren Sie sich für Politik?
Hier im Tessin, in Lugano,
in der Schweiz allgemein?
Bis jetzt nicht wirklich.
Ich lese die Zeitung.
Am besten gefällt mir
an der Schweizer Politik,
dass das Volk entscheidet.
Das berührt mich richtig.
In meinem Land
entscheidet immer die Regierung.
Wissen Sie, was das Gebäude,
dieser Palazzo hier,
für die Stadt Lugano bedeutet?
Dieser Ort -
wie heisst er und wozu dient er?
Der Palazzo ... ist das Rathaus.
Sehr gut, das Rathaus.
Zwei Dinge sind hier untergebracht:
Gemeinderat und Stadtregierung.
Grazie.
Ich übergebe meinen Kollegen das
Wort. Zuerst bitte Frau Caldelari.
Ich hätte eine Frage an den Vater -
aus reiner Neugier.
Weshalb haben Sie das Tessin gewählt
und nicht etwa Italien?
Die Wahl ist ja ein bisschen ...
In der Schule in Eritrea
lernen alle Genf kennen,
da Genf eine Weltstadt ist.
Als ich weg bin aus Eritrea,
wollte ich unbedingt nach Genf.
Aber warum dann Lugano
und nicht Genf?
Weil nicht wir entscheiden.
Als wir in Chiasso ankamen,
wurden wir nach Lugano geschickt.
Viele kommen nach Zürich,
andere nach Genf, so ist das halt.
Und waren Sie schon mal in Genf?
Ja, zweimal. Einmal allein
und einmal mit meiner Tochter.
Hat es dir gefallen?
- Ja.
Welche Stadt gefällt dir besser?
- Lugano.
Grazie.
Das Kommissionsmitglied scheint
vergessen zu haben, dass Geflüchtete,
die Asyl beantragen, nicht frei
entscheiden können, wohin sie gehen.
Der Verwaltungsapparat
entscheidet für sie.
Die Fragen werden schwieriger.
Sie sagten, am politischen System
der Schweiz gefalle Ihnen,
dass das Volk entscheidet.
Wie entscheidet das Volk?
In welcher Form?
Das Volk macht Referenden.
Es entscheidet, ob Ja oder Nein.
Wenn ein Gesetz kommt
oder wenn etwas passiert,
wenn die Regierung
oder die Gemeinde etwas anstösst,
entscheidet das Volk,
ob es das will oder nicht.
Es gibt noch andere Arten, wie
man in der Schweiz entscheiden kann.
Sie sagen: Wenn man
mit einem Vorschlag der Regierung
nicht einverstanden ist, kann man
entscheiden, ob man ihn annimmt.
Es gibt noch eine andere Form,
mit der das Volk mitbestimmen kann.
Auch wenn das Gesetz klar festhält,
dass sich Einbürgerungstest
und Anhörung
inhaltlich nicht überschneiden soll-
ten, halten sich nicht alle daran.
Dawit ist verunsichert.
Ich glaube, es gibt zwei Sachen,
wenn ich nicht falsch liege,
nicht nur eine.
Es gibt das eine, wenn das Volk
nicht einverstanden ist.
Aber in der Schweiz
können die Bürger/-innen auch ...
... Dinge entscheiden.
Wir bestimmen mit.
Die Bürger können Vorschläge machen.
- Der Regierung.
Und wie nennt man das?
Referendum?
Nein, das andere.
Die Initiative. Die Volksinitiative.
Die Volksinitiative.
Jedes Kommissionsmitglied
kann Fragen stellen.
Aber es gibt die Grundregel,
dass wir keine Fragen stellen,
die ein Durchschnittsbürger
nicht beantworten könnte.
Initiative und Referendum
gelten als komplizierte Konzepte
und gehören generell
nicht zu den klassischen Fragen,
die wir den Bewerbern stellen.
Noch eine Frage: Welche Sprache
sprechen Sie in Ihrer Familie?
Zu Hause Italienisch
und oft auch Tigrinya.
Sprechen Sie noch andere Sprachen?
Sì.
Ich spreche Amharisch,
Englisch und ein wenig Arabisch.
Okay, grazie.
- Prego.
Wie sprichst du
mit deinen Geschwistern?
Ich spreche fast nur Italienisch.
Italienisch? Danke.
Liebe Kollegen,
gibt es weitere Fragen?
Nein?
Dann bedanken wir uns und
wünschen Ihnen einen guten Abend.
Viel Erfolg in der Schule.
Mir gibt es Kraft,
wenn Hermela bei mir ist.
Weil sie meine Tochter ist.
Sie beruhigt mich.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie das für Hermela ist,
aber für mich ist es wichtig.
Siehst du? Ich wusste, dass sie dich
etwas zum Palazzo Civico fragen.
Wer ist hier das Genie?
Ich habe es gewusst - und bingo!
Und du konntest nur dank mir
richtig antworten.
Dank mir hast du bestanden, Papa.
Für Dawit ist es noch zu früh,
sich zu freuen.
Es steht zu viel auf dem Spiel.
Jetzt kommt das lange Warten
auf den Entscheid.
* Langsame, sanfte Klavierklänge *
In Freienbach
versucht sich Andreas an Frage 59.
Kennen Sie den Unterschied zwischen
einer Kommission und einer Behörde?
Eine Kommission ist beratend
und eine Behörde ausführend.
Im Kanton Schwyz
haben die Gemeinden die Wahl:
Entweder werden die Kenntnisse
der Gesuchstellenden
bei der Anhörung getestet
oder sie legen einen
Sprach- und Grundwissenstest ab.
Freienbach hat entschieden,
beides zu machen.
Gut. Dann hätten wir gerne
die Namen von fünf Bundesräten.
Diese Namen ...
Ja, Namen sind mir ein Gräuel.
Der ehemalige ...
Verteidigung war ...
Das war für mich
eine sehr schlimme Erfahrung.
Die Bundesräte
sind eine wichtige Sache.
Wie hiessen die Bundesräte?
Verdammt noch mal, wie hiessen die?
Es war weg.
Es war wie ein schwarzes Loch.
Und die Befragung hört nicht auf,
sie geht ja weiter.
Wie heissen die fünf Ortschaften
der Gemeinde Freienbach?
Wie heisst die Legislative
auf Gemeindestufe?
Was ist ein passives
und was ein aktives Wahlrecht?
Abstimmungsthemen auf Bundesebene.
Dann bitte zwei traditionelle,
typische Schweizer Sportarten.
Bei den anderen Fragen, die kamen,
kriegte ich nicht mal mit,
dass ich sie beantwortete,
da ich immer noch dachte:
"Wenn man
nicht mal die Bundesräte kennt,
wie soll man da
eingebürgert werden?"
Die Hilflosigkeit ...
Ich hatte schon viele Prüfungen.
Aber solche Blackouts
kannte ich gar nicht von mir.
Ich wünsche es niemandem.
Wer wählt den Ständerat
im Kanton Schwyz?
Bei der Anhörung
geht es eben nicht um Leben und Tod.
Es ist wie eine Prüfung -
eine Prüfung besteht man oder nicht.
Was verstehen Sie
unter Gewaltentrennung?
Gewaltentrennung.
* Sanfte, sphärische Klänge *
Jetzt ist es aus. Jetzt ...
Für Andreas
ist das die eine Frage zu viel.
Wie vor fünf Jahren seine Tochter
kommt er vor der Kommission
ins Straucheln.
Etwas, das Sie in der DDR
nicht hatten. Gewaltentrennung.
Trennung zwischen ... Juris...
Exekutive, Jus...
Jurist
und Legislative.
Nach 50 Min. und über 80 Fragen
ist die Anhörung vorbei.
Andreas atmet erleichtert auf.
Nie schien ihm der Schweizer Pass
ferner als heute.
Somit wäre ich fertig.
Frau Fehr wird Ihnen erklären,
wie es weitergeht.
Die Einbürgerungsbehörde
wird jetzt entscheiden,
ob Sie eingebürgert werden
oder nicht.
Sie werden dann
einen Beschluss erhalten.
Gut. Danke, dass Sie gekommen sind.
- Danke auch.
(Mehrere) Schönen Abend. Ade.
- Ade. Gleichfalls.
Dann wünsche ich noch einen
schönen Abend.- (Alle) Gleichfalls.
Ich habe so viele Fragen
nicht beantwortet.
Ich habe mehr mit mir selber
gehadert als mit der Kommission.
Ich hatte das noch
von meiner Tochter in Erinnerung.
Sie waren der Meinung,
sie habe sich nicht vorbereitet,
und sie ist durchgefallen.
Es war schon
eine äusserst makabere Erfahrung.
Viele Monate sind seit dem Beginn
des Verfahrens vergangen.
Nun hat die Warterei ein Ende.
Endlich ist die ersehnte Post da.
Ana konnte es sich nicht verkneifen,
einen Blick hineinzuwerfen.
Aber sie hat den Umschlag
wieder zugeklebt,
um die Überraschung
nicht zu verderben.
Machst du ihn auf?
- Sì.
Dai.
Komm, lass mich.
Das ist so wichtig.
Es könnte wichtig sein. Wer weiss?
Ah.
(Ana) Das hier ist Papas.
(Chiara) Freust du dich?
- (Ana) Bist du zufrieden?
"Mit dem Entscheid
des Bürgerrates von Pontresina
hat Chiara Corona das Bürgerrecht
der Gemeinde Pontresina erworben."
Schön. Wirklich.
Das Ziel ist ...
... erreicht worden.
- Ja.
Es fehlen noch ein paar Schriften,
aber schön, schön.
Das meiste ist bereits vorbei.
Der grosse Teil ist jetzt vorbei.
Schau, Mama - ich werde es lami-
nieren lassen und draufschreiben:
"Das Wichtigste der Welt."
Wir fühlen uns
hier auf jeden Fall akzeptiert,
aber das ist gerade ...
Der Hit.
- ... top, der Hit.
Das heisst, dass wir
für Pontresina auch wichtig sind.
Es ist etwas Zusätzliches
in meinem Dasein.
Ich fühle mich als Schweizerin.
Es war die Sache wert.
- Sì.
* Dumpfe, entspannte Klänge *
Der 1. August
ist der Nationalfeiertag.
Ich feiere ihn jedes Jahr.
Ich bin unterwegs
wie alle anderen auch.
Wir feiern so wie die anderen,
mit Freunden und Familie.
Im Tessin
kann Dawit endlich aufatmen.
Der positive Entscheid der
Stadt Lugano ist gerade eingetroffen.
Seit ich in der Schweiz bin,
war es mir wichtig,
den 1. August zu feiern,
weil ich hier lebe und arbeite.
Mein ganzes Leben ist hier.
Deshalb ist es
auch mein Nationalfeiertag.
Das ist
nicht nur eine Frage des Passes:
Nicht weil ich mich einbürgern las-
sen will, feiere ich den 1. August.
Für mich war das immer
ein wichtiger Tag.
Wie wollt ihr sie?
Mit Mayo? Ketchup?
Mayonnaise e Ketchup, questo.
Für Dawit ist es ein Sommer
voller guter Nachrichten.
Endlich hat ihm sein Chef einen
unbefristeten Vertrag angeboten.
Das Fest, das Feuerwerk -
ich liebe das
und freue mich jedes Jahr darauf.
* Donnergrollen *
Schau, da kommt ein Gewitter auf.
Das wird schwierig
mit dem Feuerwerk bei diesem Regen.
* Donnergrollen, Stimmengewirr *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Auf der Alpennordseite
ist die Stimmung im Keller.
Nach der verpatzten Anhörung
wartet Andreas
noch immer auf seinen Entscheid.
Ich habe kein gutes Gefühl.
Ich habe
mit anderen Bekannten gesprochen,
mit denen ich
die Schulung gemacht habe.
Da ...
... glaube ich nicht,
dass es geklappt hat.
Sein Sohn ist durchgefallen,
er ist durchgefallen.
Ende nächstes Jahr
dürfen sie es wiederholen.
Ich habe es mir nun einmal angetan,
nochmals ...
Ne, da sage ich mir dann: "Ne."
Ich wüsste ja nicht mal,
wie ich mich vorbereiten soll.
Jedes Mal 2'500 Fr. zu bezahlen -
ne, dafür gehe ich nicht arbeiten.
Da kann ich
auch Roulette spielen gehen.
Man muss ja nicht betteln.
Ich habe mit meiner Tochter
gesprochen und ich habe ihr gesagt,
dass ich es nicht nochmals probiere.
Wenn sie mich nicht wollen,
dann wollen sie mich nicht.
Ich muss mich nicht aufdrängen.
Erst jetzt, nach der eigenen Erfah-
rung vor der Einwanderungsbehörde,
begreift Andreas, was seine Tochter
durchgemacht haben muss.
Ich habe mich dafür entschuldigt,
dass ich ihr das angetan habe,
dass ich gesagt habe,
sie solle es unbedingt machen.
Wie sie da ...
Wenn ein junger Mensch
so auseinandergenommen wird,
ist das noch schlimmer
als für jemanden,
der schon ...
... lange genug auf der Welt ist,
der viel mitgekriegt und erlebt hat.
Aber für einen so jungen Menschen
ist es richtig furchtbar.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ciao, come vai?
- Bene, bene.
Meine Kinder sind hier geboren
und fühlen sich als Schweizer.
Wenn ich sie frage,
ob sie Eritreer oder Schweizer sind,
sagen sie: "Halb, halb."
Sie wissen doch kaum,
wo Eritrea ist.
Sie waren noch nie dort.
Jetzt, wo der Schweizer Pass
in Reichweite ist,
wird
eine Reise nach Eritrea greifbar.
Seit 13 Jahren hofft Dawit
auf ein Wiedersehen mit seinem Vater.
Er würde ihm so gern
seine Enkelkinder vorstellen.
* Langsame, sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Mal aufmachen.
Die Schlussrechnung.
Ich brauche meine Brille,
sonst kann ich es nicht lesen.
Ui.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Wahnsinn.
"Der Bürgerrechtsbewerber
erfüllt die im Gesetz vorgesehenen
Einbürgerungsvoraussetzungen."
"Andreas Luther wird das Bürgerrecht
der Gemeinde Freienbach erteilt."
Wow.
Ich hatte
ein total negatives Gefühl.
"Gegen den Beschluss
kann Beschwerde eingelegt werden."
Wenn man das kriegt, dann legt
man doch keine Beschwerde mehr ein.
Ja, ich freue mich wahnsinnig.
Gleich mal weiterschicken ...
Hallo, Lisa,
ich habe gerade Bescheid gekriegt.
Es gibt eine Person,
die er sofort informieren will:
seine jüngste Tochter Lisa.
Ja, wir können heute Abend
anstossen.
Mama habe ich es
soeben auch geschickt.
Ich bin total happy
und stehe völlig neben mir.
V.a. wenn man sich überlegt,
wo man herkommt.
Vor 30 Jahren war der Mauerfall.
Vorher hätte man
nicht daran gedacht,
dass man
in der Schweiz arbeiten,
geschweige denn die Schweizer
Staatsbürgerschaft erhalten könnte.
Ich habe gerade geschaut.
Jetzt lädt das Handy.
Als Stromer
hätte mir klar sein sollen,
dass es ausgeschaltet ist,
wenn es nicht leuchtet.
Ich stehe noch etwas neben mir.
Jetzt hast du es geschafft,
jetzt bist du Schweizer.
Ne, erst mal bin ich ...
Ja, ich bin auch Schweizer.
Es ist ein bisschen zu neu für mich.
Ich habe jetzt das Bürgerrecht.
Prost, mein Schatz.
Prost, Papa. Auf dich.
Auf dich, danke, danke.
Hach.
Ich hab dich lieb.
Ich dich auch, mein Schatz.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch nochmals.
- Danke schön.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Es ist Wahnsinn.
Es ist ... Ach, ja.
Das kann man gar nicht fassen.
* Sphärische Klänge, sanfter Gesang *
Auch für Dawit und die Kinder
wird die Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft
greifbar.
Sie setzt dem schwierigen
Flüchtlingsstatus ein Ende.
An diesem Abend sieht die Zukunft
für die Familie rosig aus.
Ich lebe für sie, für ihre Zukunft.
Meine Kinder
kommen voran in der Schule.
Sie sind die Zukunft.
Ich denke jetzt an sie.
* Applaus *
Im März 2020 hat das Coronavirus
alles stillgelegt.
Auch die Verwaltung
blieb nicht verschont.
Einbürgerungsverfahren
wurden teilweise gestoppt.
Nicht im Oberengadin,
in einem abgelegenen Bündner Tal.
Sì, perché sono tutti ...
(Ana) Wie elegant, Paolo.
Hätten Sie gerne eine Quittung?
- Ja, gern.
Gut, vielen Dank.
Nach 30 Jahren in der Schweiz
geniessen Paolo und Ana diesen Tag.
Er ist Abschluss
eines langen, steinigen Weges.
... auch noch unterschreiben.
Ich beginne hier.
* Ein Mann spricht rätoromanisch. *
Der Schweizer Pass,
das ist die Kirsche auf der Torte.
Jedes Jahr erhalten 45'000 Menschen
den Schweizer Pass.
Eine stolze Zahl.
Und doch hat die Schweiz
eine der tiefsten Einbürgerungsraten
in ganz Europa.
Sì. Oddio.
Fino al 2030, ciao. Cavoli.
Sì?
- Sì, dieci anni.
* Sanfte Klänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020